[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we want
today we got shandbag hi so good to see
you
i want you to face the cat to cheat out
the cheat out
[Laughter]
uh but seriously did you say your family
just moved to l.a or
they did yes they didn't move is that a
good thing it's an amazing thing
it really is are you from toronto or
wherever toronto okay toronto
six six six can can you say which which
family
my sister yeah older younger she is my
older sister by two years so i feel like
we're kind of like the same and she
moved down here to work with me too so
it's like double how come you don't
sound very canadian
um toronto is not really light i guess
oops do you say ut but you know what
jordan peterson is from toronto and he's
the most canadian
sounding person on the other hand we all
sound like kermit the frog
no like it's kind of like this i guess
it's like the stereotypical accent
oh yeah but you also do you say toronto
or it's like toronto
say toronto toronto toronto
toronto toronto yeah toronto america
americans say toronto but then you guys
say toronto
toronto yeah toronto china
china have you guys been to canada yes
yes toronto everybody here
i'm not i have not still it's on the
list to go you know i would never meet
somebody from canada who's never been to
america
and i feel like in america one in 16
people has been to canada
we don't travel much out here i feel
like every other country travels
everywhere except for the
us where do people go in america for
vacation like where's las vegas
around the us orlando no as a kid
told me i'm wrong hawaii yeah orlando
yeah if you're rich most people in
america don't have a passport
so i do like road trips that road trip
is a big thing we have a lot of national
parks so like i hear people doing like
road trips through national parks like
yosemite zion and that kind of stuff
yeah i'm seeing you here like you didn't
have any childhood vacations
i did i just don't remember a lot of
them i'm grateful i didn't leave the us
until i was like 25.
why i think that's the norm that's the
norm probably yeah i just never
you know i mean we weren't like rich or
anything we didn't go on vacation
you have a lot of siblings because
that's what makes it expensive
wait what's a lot i thought you had like
a brother and a sister no i have two
brothers and i have one sister
that's a lie i love my sister that's a
lot maybe not the mexican standards
four yeah because well i grew up with
four but i've no one's ever been like
that's a lot of kids what depends on
what you're talking to
oh four kids all the same house yeah
because like
my both my parents had like 12 brothers
and sisters that's a lot but they both
grew up with like two
you know what i mean like there was two
in the house but like there's a bunch of
you know
ages age difference you know just
different daddies
half brothers and sisters yeah yeah four
in the same house but in the same house
is a lot cause if you think about
road trips or if you want to take a
plane together that's like
six tickets you gotta get like
disneyland for four what's that oh [ __ ]
that
it's like my parents were sweating the
whole time and they were we did that
once and they were like oh jesus
it's probably a thousand now if you have
four kids what's it take at least yeah
at least not including yourselves dude
and then food and then other stuff we
don't get
i said can we get a park hopper and my
mom broke down crying
so that's expensive that's expensive
yeah that's super expensive i've been
wrangling all those kids like the whole
day
it's like a mess but now at least they
have those like backpacks with the
leashes on kids and stuff so you can
kind of like let them
run oh you're gonna be one of those
parents oh what's your take on parents
taking their kids to disney but like too
soon like these guys do
i mean i think if you have the money to
do it again when they can remember oh we
got it
[Music]
he did not remember we took him when
like was it three months or eight months
like he was a wobbly head and he didn't
see any understanding
he was like six months six months did
you guys have fun or it was like yeah
[ __ ] yeah
yeah wow you have a baby at disneyland
ride the ride parents are never smiling
i liked it i thought it was cool
and then i wanted to take him back but
then the whole [ __ ] pandemic happened
and now i really want to take him
because he's like aware and he would
love it
and now well now you can take him to
star wars land which is like just a star
wars mall
yeah really nothing really to do yeah
it's pretty wet you just buy stuff you
just get the blue drink or whatever
right you got to buy a pass to go to the
mall
to go to the mall basically you go to
the star wars star wars mall well i
thought the same thing about
disney world i went to disney world
because i used to do photography and i
flew out with make a wish foundation and
they had a bunch of kids
you know go as their last wish to disney
world
and i was like goddammit all this had to
do was spend money all day
the entire time they get a budget too
for the future they make the
wish kids they just brought in there is
like all right now to do all these
things you need money and then they're
just like oh
[ __ ] wow they're like can we get the
kids backpacks
for free or something and the disney's
like [ __ ] though
where you're going you won't need this
backpack the [ __ ] no no
you should at least let them borrow it
yeah for real like just give the kid the
[ __ ] like 10
bag bro that's crazy
so i actually never been to disneyland
because my disney world experience was
so negative
yeah usually people that aren't born in
california they don't give a [ __ ] about
that that's true
huh or if they didn't grow up on disney
movies oh i jade though
once you go to world you don't give a
[ __ ] about land anymore dude is it whack
land is so whack dude i gotta go to the
world though i've never been a world
war i don't know the world is upside
down all around it's [ __ ] crazy bro
is it because it's bigger like you've
never gone
that's the best part honestly once
you're an adult when you're a kid you're
like this is the most boring [ __ ] of all
human time
all human time yeah you just like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] mom and dad and but then
yeah as an adult it's actually sick
that's funny i saw a calendar of what
days people don't go
and that's when you should go it's like
on a tuesday in the middle of summer or
something
in the middle of summer i would think
like tuesday november
yeah yeah when school's in session or
whatever
yeah what's one of the things you're
trying to um take your daughter to as
soon as she's like
able to oh man there's a place in canada
called banff
oh i want to go to banff it looks really
cool badass [ __ ]
it's that's what it stands for i said no
i don't know it's just like
when you think about canada as a
four-year-old you're probably like oh
like mountains and like mooses i don't
ever think about
canada oh okay no sex i like that yeah
that's actually i don't think canada i
don't think about you at all that's
right
as a californian honestly i love you as
a counselor everybody watching right now
is like i actually don't
ever think about canada either um and we
think about you guys i honestly think in
canada
70 of the news is american news because
we're trash
and i came here and the only time i ever
heard canada mention is when it was
chilly they're like there's a cold front
coming from canada
that's so long but seattle nothing i
will blame you guys for anything
alaska yeah no i'm sorry you guys are
awesome but what so what's banff
okay so it's like that like it's like if
god came to earth you would want him to
go to banff first to be like they did a
good job
like wow like it's very naturey very
beautiful
yeah they did a good job like you didn't
[ __ ] this portion of you
everything else was like remember this
in the rest of your tour
i want to go to whistler for
snowboarding and in the summer for
mountain biking do you snowboard
of course you do it's fun yeah you i
don't take you as an outdoorsy person
though
i'm not really but um but for the gram
okay oh okay there it is the pictures
with the baby with the mountains and the
billy goats and all that
there's billy goats coaster west coast
it's west coast so it's closer to
seattle whistler yeah oh maybe we could
drive there
you guys could drive there you guys are
on a cake for driving around huh yeah
we've been
doing it you'll see borders are blocked
right now though
i feel like bart loves to road trip but
i don't think you do it's actually the
opposite is it really
yeah i was a big road tripper and he's
the yeah bar always like
wide road trip when you could fly yeah
all they did was road trip
yeah he was always like why are you
gonna drive there like we can just get
in 30 minutes like why
why why waste your time but because i
was a four kids
road trips all the time i hate road
trips yeah really
i'm able to hate them instead i always
thought that people who grew up road
tripping love road tripping well not
necessarily
no i hate being in the car now do you
get motion sickness
i get hell emotion sickness you guys
don't do it right though you're supposed
to get add
and pull over every time you see weird
[ __ ] no and then it takes you 10 hours
to get there that's what's fun about it
i've driven to vegas with you
it was like that why flight it why fly
to vegas in like in like an hour
or [ __ ] take a 10 hour detour and you
end up in utah
that is the truth people on road trips
are so like fascinated with like getting
there as fast as possible
but i'm assuming the joy is in yeah the
journey we pulled over like every 30
minutes now every hour
just to check [ __ ] out it's so fun well
my fame is white trash so they just they
think that this stuff is remarkable
like if they see the ball of yarn yeah
they think it's
that's dumb the mysteries how many
mystery spots have you been to oh dude i
went to meteor crater which is like a
four-hour diversion when you're on
[ __ ] yeah and it's just to see a hole in
the ground not a meteorite
that's what americans do because i know
exactly what you that's that joe dirt
meteor thing
yeah dude and i my parents they were
like this is amazing
and we're kids it's like this is just a
[ __ ] hole in the ground i'd like to
see it how big is the hole
it's probably active yeah and they still
have the meteor it's like this big and
they're like
this is what created this the meteor
still there you're ungrateful
no the meter's not still there it's in
the museum they have shards of it around
but it's not a big [ __ ] meteor that
would be sick
like a moon that landed on the earth
like a world ending rock
you got to see a little bit of space and
you're [ __ ] on it i love space
but i was looking down not up i like to
look up at space
he has apps to like tell you the
formation
of the [ __ ] constellations
you went back now you have a different
lens on it i think you'd have a more
grateful lens
you really think i would like to see the
holy grail i definitely do you said
there was little shards of meteor
you don't know me at all preserved down
the street it's in a museum
today's video is brought to you by feels
cbd isn't about
what you feel but it's about what you
don't feel such as
pain stress anxiety heartbreak and those
three things i've been feeling a lot
these days i don't know where it's
coming from
but i said to myself let me pull out
some
feels yeah drip it on my tongue and see
if i can maybe i do the whole bottle but
thank god they got a hotline that i can
call and say hey
how much should i take as a dose yeah
maybe you don't need the whole bottle
yeah yeah but these days i've been
feeling like i need a whole damn bottle
right but i took a couple of drops i
said to myself
this feels much better you turn into a
medieval person i said this to myself
i said to myself i need to go back in
time
yeah you know because sometimes it's
tough you feel anxiety
something's crazy is going on you can't
go to sleep but you still got to work
the next day
come back here and make funny videos you
know so fields is awesome like that
where it just chills you out
and you're able to go to sleep you feel
centered and they have a hotline
that you can call in case you don't know
how much to take but don't take the
whole bottle
and feels also has a monthly membership
that makes self-care super easy you just
sign up
forget about it and every single month
it just comes to your door
right when you need it and right now
they got a really good deal if you go to
feels.com
off the record that's f e a l s dot off
the record you get
fifty percent off plus free shipping
that's fifty percent off plus free
shipping go to fields.com
off the record and just remember it's f
e f-e-a-l-s-com
if i'd done something once i think i've
done it every time that's why
i've been to montreal and i was like
this is just like america except they
have gravy fries
that's a very american view it's just
like it
i thought it was more like europe
because it had like cobblestones
actually never been to montreal but i've
heard that it looks like europe
i didn't look down and i don't look down
anywhere i go so
i'm sorry i couldn't tell you
i'm not a fan of looking down is it only
like this way
forward-thinking guy here we should do a
video like that we take
steve across america and try to try and
impress steve
i can shoot on anything yeah but that's
the challenge that's a challenge to get
you the nutshell
that's how i felt about uh grand canyon
i know in popular opinion but i was like
what the [ __ ] is this
granted i was like nine it's huge i've
never even been it's breathtaking grand
canyon is pretty breathtaking
i wasn't not i know i said i'm probably
i will never go to the grand canyon the
size of it literally
takes your breath away like you stand
there and just go
and you're like whoa and there's so many
parts you're like
100 i could die yeah a strong gust of
wind dead
yeah i'm out that's my mouth colors
right at the edges
well i still ride the edge so i'm gonna
go to the grand canyon
you're blowing my mind i never thought
you would like girl you gotta get the
picture
i keep forgetting the shot's not good
you got to get right up to the edge yeah
and then she goes back in her camper and
leaves exactly
have you grabbed like you know they have
the shallow parts of the cliff where you
can grab it look
it looks like you're hanging off the
edge i haven't done that
how far would you go roughing it like
what level until you go
like i've actually i've never been
camping really um
do you want to do a cottage i would like
i'd like to glamp i got to start slow
curious a little bit i'm curious for
sure yeah i don't like to get i
also am like if there is something that
bites
i will get bitten so i'm concerned about
mosquitos love you
anything black flies mosquitoes
centipedes
a bumblebee will figure it out for me
like everybody wants the blood so
i'm worried about that even a cricket
huh even a cricket
uh just to get a taste so i am concerned
about that
but i would i would like to give it a
try maybe rv the way that you guys do it
with the
with the air thing that you have it
looks quite lovely we were just camping
and there was a family in an rv
next to us and for three days we haven't
seen them leave the rv
oh they just we saw them open up and say
hi and they closed their
like curtain and that was it and we're
like so what's the point of camping yeah
it's been hot that was like 90 something
degrees oh that's why
not even trying to take a step out
though and just like we didn't see them
yeah
why go there then yeah
a lot of families are like that they
just had these big ass hooked up rvs
and they were just parked there and i
was like i guess this is camping for
them
yeah yeah is that person better than me
no
i don't think so it's like stay home
then right i don't know
i think they want to get away from home
but then they don't want to go
they don't really want to get away from
home yeah but then their whole their rv
is like hooked up right so it's got like
wi-fi
tv exactly you're getting away like it
was like a tour bus
that thing was massive but see what they
do is fun because they go hang out with
hot people
it does change your experience of the
outdoors how do you guys find so many
friends
just meeting people through like how
many groups of friends do you have
they they use this site called adult
friend finder i can't believe it
that's really useful so don't spread it
it works people don't
you have all the hot friends you can
talk about there's always 30 people in
the picture
so i'll be trying to zoom in to see you
these people i know i'm like okay
that yeah i don't know who the face is i
don't even know either there's just 30
other people you had access to
not homo just random people yep i never
met him
it's like you're like you know the like
you have to be this tall to ride the to
ride the ride
have to be this hot to ride to go on
their camping rv trip no i think we just
get a lot of it just i mean like you
know you have your different pockets of
friends right like you have like your tv
friends your musician friends like yes
you do
you know so many people look at your
baby shower
hollywood people don't even know who the
hell they are no we know who they are
because they're [ __ ] famous
yeah but i don't know who they are oh
okay i know their names i don't know who
they are
i don't think they want a trip with me i
don't think we're that kind of friends
going on a trip is a different level of
friendship
i see than a networking party exactly
which is my baby shower
like i see daffy on mockit was there yes
maybe ap on crockett is actually how me
and jared met
how's that what is that story because i
moved to la and i took a hosting class
and i took one they got classes for that
[ __ ] yes
exactly but i went and i was like i'm
far superior to everybody here i cannot
return
so i never returned but i met one girl
there and she was like
kept hitting me up to come like hang out
with her and so then literally eight
months ago fine i'll go hang
out with you she's like i'm dating this
guy atheon crockett right now
he has he's going to a party let's meet
him there so we go to the party and it
was jared's party
and how does he know atheon atheon was
managing him at the time because jared
does music yes
what's with who's atheon atheon crockett
he was on wilding out the negro
the negotiator i thought i thought it
was good has a very dj name by the way
super talented improv stand up dances
i'm super talented dude so you see jared
and was it like ah
who is that guy literally at the time i
was still dating somebody from toronto
but it was not going well toronto i
actually left
excuse me thank you sorry i was dating
someone from toronto and it wasn't going
well but i actually had left
toronto living with that person and it
was such a terrible experience so
we like tried to make it work long
distance but it wasn't working we were
in the same house so
i was going through a fight with him and
then i saw jared and i literally got
this immediate like rush over me like
did it say rescue me
it was like he would be the perfect
revenge [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] perfect and i just he's a beautiful
man
he is a beautiful man yes he has
captivating eyes
it okay yeah
sure yeah i think joe's flirting with
your man
yeah and then that was it and then you
were like i gotta talk like a year later
for us to actually meet up but you
didn't revenge [ __ ] for a whole year
no because i was still in the you know i
mean i was still in the midst of
something with that person
i just put a placeholder on him i was
like when ready
yeah and so i waited till his birthday
the following year sent a very nice
comment
for the birthday and then he dm'd me and
then we revenge [ __ ] wow
got it which is actually a month after i
officially got out of that relationship
oh [ __ ] you stuck it out for another
year i did
it's a long-term revenge [ __ ] that's it
yeah yeah when you know you know
yeah it's true it's like you're playing
pokemon you're like i'm gonna use this
later
and you put it back in your deck and
when the time was right you said
bam you don't have to say who it is but
is there somebody you have in mind that
if your current relationship didn't work
out
you would go and have sex with them yes
no
no time wasted basketball i don't
i don't for me i'm like geo add me to
the list
okay for me it's like pokemon cards
steve's like ah yeah i took you what's
your stash look like
a bunch of energy and they don't know
what to do with it
sure i'm trying to make it work i don't
know um yeah no definitely not
i'm a one-woman kind of guy well you are
i'm just saying that
if in the event oh but there's no backup
plan i have no like
oh this person samuel i don't have a
backup plan either
i'm in a fresh new one so that is my
backup plan
oh well not like that but like there's
no backup plan because it's fun
you gotta wait ask me when there's
baggage in the relationship i think
at that point i still have people i'd
like to have sex with um
oh yeah thank you oh [ __ ]
um i don't have anybody that i i don't
have something i think of in the same
this big old smile
yeah you don't want to [ __ ] ryan come on
look at that guy
i just got to know him i gotta i gotta
see what he does
joe does the fun [ __ ] he does the funny
thing i do
what do you do that's fine in the
bedroom but he looks like
batteries
i'm pretty bland i'll suck my own dick
for you
for you i'll do that for myself hell
yeah i'll beat joe i'll eat my own ass
and suck my own dick
i'll take yoga lessons so i could suck
myself off in front of you dude i've
taken yoga and that's i [ __ ] hate
yoga can't do yoga i like yoga
you're you're you're making your chances
get lower and lower that's fine
i i'm very comfortable with who i am i
don't even talk or make a guy
i don't even get naked yeah yeah i'm
never nude
never nude do you keep the socks on oh
it depends depends on how freaky the
mood is yeah it's got a freaky move for
the soccer come on
you know once the once the nice white
like ankle legs
like socks come out it's going crazy yes
ryan
it took me a long time to see jared's
feet really why are you shy about them
kept his socks on all the time so yeah
sandals and socks kind of fella
he was sandals and socks yeah sandals
and socks are never shorts i read this
somewhere where
uh women can achieve orgasms like better
or easier if they have
their feet warm like in having socks on
or something
is that have you heard of that i've
heard that from one of the two hot to
handle castmates
i've never heard it anywhere else but i
read it somewhere yeah
okay i forgot where so i can't maybe it
was like on
top ten ways to give her a harder orgasm
or something like that she caused my
hardcore
[ __ ] 55 ways to make him come every
time i'm like there's one just suck my
dick
that's true it's not rocket science for
guys we should be reading that [ __ ] for
girls
yeah but it's too long maybe having
socks on makes it better so that's nice
though
if that's the case for men maybe that's
why he had him on and i was judging him
but he was actually
he does like them uh i think he was just
feet self-conscious
really does have busted feet yeah kind
of
i will remember that you took it off
you're like i see why you did that and
then on top of that too when your feet
self-conscious and you always have socks
on they're like a level of
pale that's just not comfortable to the
human eye yeah
so it compounds the the issue right
right
i think feet are so ugly i don't get it
like i would never
i'm just like you've never seen nice
feet supposed to be yeah but it's never
like the object of fixation i love feet
i love feet i love hands i look at that
my feet are ugly they're almost animal
they're not ugly i love his feet
your [ __ ] toenails some of them are
kind of like that's the back heel it
looks like a [ __ ] yeah that's
nasty it is nasty but like your foot the
overall foot the toenail to the toe
raise
the fungus is just creeping up on your
toe dude oh
david snow has cute feet though he has
very nice feet you have nice feet you
have nice hands
he has nice feet might drive right now
but
from afar i do like them no you have
great feet and i direct i decorate them
i have a tow ring
i know i know i think that's a foot i
like it yeah don't show them put it on
only fans only
don't show them for free no no no no no
she always shows them for free i'm
always looking at that
[ __ ] with your red toenails do you want
to show your feet i'll show my feet
sure yeah i got to get a sock off though
i'm happy to show my foot it's [ __ ]
it's just the foot i'll show you my i
show you my [ __ ] cracked heels
here you go you sickos my feet's black
first
i've ever seen your feet there you go
you're sick
so look at it look at it get it get your
[ __ ] nut
you piece of [ __ ] i got grip though i've
got good grip yeah his [ __ ] is white i
got grip
yeah i got off-road tire feet these are
real off-road feet it's black joe's
really nice he does have nice feet
they're really nice arches
i heard that my my fingers are good to
[ __ ] too
oh my god those are some [ __ ]
fingers for sure
and suckable fingers
[Music]
[Applause]
i